chers amis
chers amis réjouissez-vous une fois de
plus vous allez pouvoir constater votre
chance d'avoir enfin parmi les habitants
de l'île aux enfants un être doué d'une
intelligence extraordinaire et d'un
grand sens de l'organisation ont écouté
vraiment aux non messieurs travelling
vraiment si c'est trop de compliments en
ma faveur non vraiment voulu heurter
malgré des styles que puis je faire pour
vous a peut-être signer un contrat a
donné que prétend son génome vous n'avez
ni une grande intelligence n'est un
grand sens de l'organisation le
lendemain non je ne parle pas de vous
voyons enfin je parle de moi excusez moi
monsieur travelling je n'avais pas
compte mais ma visite de trop important
pour que je continue à me corrélée avec
vous toute façon c'est l'oubli
qui est concerné par la nouvelle idée
géniale
à je devine votre joie et votre
impatience aussi je vais tout vous dire
j'ai décidé de changer cet heureux ce
local mais il est très joli une pompe
pour ce bocal melon me suis-je ce bocal
de tous
les sites rising vous voulez changer le
kiosque et de julie me bien sûr n'est
plus du tout à la mode et là quelques
nouveaux projets que j'ai moi même
dessiné cette nuit et que je vais vous
proposez vous n'aurez que l'embarras du
choix ils sont tous super bonne je ne
veux pas changer mon kiosque et je ne
regarderai pas vos projets ridicule
vous avez décidé mon voeu est de toute
façon c'est du travelling de première
catégorie
vous n'avez vraiment pas beaucoup de
goût ça m'est égal
pour écoutez je vous en prie tous les
deux arrêtés à arrêter de vous disputer
écoute julie tu peux quand même jeter un
coup d'oeil à ses dessins bien ça
n'engage à rien allez si tu veux
vraiment c'est pour te faire plaisir
voilà là vous comprenez monsieur trà
vinh le choc était trop fort vous
l'avais un peu surprise mais je suis sûr
que je lis va être séduite par vos
projets sauvegarde je consens à la vie
montre côté d'abord serré vous là me a
les
doigts après que nous n'étions pas
vraiment fâché cette petite querelle
n'est plus qu'un mauvais souvenir
maintenant voyons vos projets et bien
comme nous sommes à l'ère des voyages
dans l'espace j'ai pensé à cette idée
géniale que j'ai intitulé destination
lune et vous voulez que je passe ma vie
la donne je vois ce sont ces petits
hublots qui vous gène mans je l'admets
mon second projet va vous séduire
beaucoup plus mais mais mais si tu ne
vas te concile ou non c'est une
illustration super de notre société
industrielle
il est génial destin mais attendez
attendez attendez mon troisième projet
tend encore plus d'avant garde et je lui
ai intitulé caire démonter un kiosque
étudié pour la prochaine attaque des
martiens mais ça n'est pas un kiosque
c'est un abri
faut vivre avec son temps non non non
mais monsieur travelling nous n'avons
plus rien à craindre vous savez que les
photos prises récemment sur mars pour
prouver qu'il n'y avait sur cette
planète aucun habitant de plus de plus
rien ne nous prouve que les
extraterrestres s'il existe soit
agressif de toute façon je ne changerai
pas mon coffre contre l'un de ses
projets
de toute façon j'ai obtenu de monsieur
du club le président de la fed de l'île
aux enfants son accord pour changer
cette horreur de kiosques
travelling comprenez là mais enfin ce ce
kiosque elle y est habitué il fait
partie du décor de notre île depuis
depuis des années taisez vous ce kiosque
serait une antiquité et oui nous l'avons
toujours connu
mais
alors sa chance tout je pourrais le
faire classer monument historique à ce
serait bon pour le tourisme côté
français il faut vous trouviez la date
de construction de ce cross et s'il est
assez ancien je le serai ce monument
historique à sa place bon je vous laisse
à ce soit au revoir au revoir
françois le drame c'est que nous ne
savons pas qu'on se cust qu'elles
étaient construits
julie j'ai une idée j'ai une idée là
kazim kazim kazim y revient vite mon
vieux vite voilà j'arrive à grandvaux
bravo tu es tu es très souple casimir
est ce que la machine à remonter le
temps est toujours en état de marche un
évidemment formidable entre casimir
d'avis tu l'as cherché graphique chic
j'adore remonter dans le temps oui
qu'est ce que tu veux faire et bien judy
grâce à la machine de casimir nous
allons remonter dans le temps et quand
nous verrons le kiosque disparaître des
d'écoles nous connaîtrons alors la date
de sa construction
je crois que j'ai compris
vous n'êtes pas très bon alors nous
partons à l'aube
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à quelle époque salut écouter
à mon avis d'après les costumes que nous
portons nous devrions être aux au xviie
siècle oui et je pense vraisemblablement
sont soumis 13 oui bien ma machine
marche bien et sport ah oui
mais le kiosque existait déjà mais alors
écoutez il faut repartir plus loin dans
le passé venez
vous sauver vous face aux vieux
travelling alors qu'elle si on fait
comment mais madame toujours aussi
plaisante imbert je vous permets pas je
suis victor & média travelling officier
des gardes du cardinal je vais vous
faire embastiller mois
il est devenu fou et bien pas du tout et
semir casimir ouais ce n'est pas le
véritable travelling dont celui ci c'est
un ancêtre de travailler dans ces
conditions il faut vite repartir vite
sinon elle a vite déchanté
au total un bon jour et porte en temps
[Musique]
ça alors c'est incroyable je n'aurais
jamais cru que mon père c'était aussi
ancien cela prouve qu'il est de bonne
qualité
le rigolo laissez moi passer
encore un autre autre haring jeu sous le
futur y entrave linus
rigolus à celle en sus casey mears minus
a entendu françois il m'a insulté c'est
qu'ils restent calmes à l'époque nous
sommes arrivés les rebelles ont envahi
la gaule et nous sommes des gaulois
alors alors dix soldats romains ne
doivent pas être loin tant pis d'un
pouce carré machine a
expliqué sa commandite on boit on remet
un ego ego et dont on est sans arrêt
kazuma toi aussi tu
as tout en russie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien les enfants sont là nous sommes
revenir à notre époque nous avons eu
chaud bon moi j'aimais bien victorius à
gravelines eu ça oui seulement avec tout
ça nous ne savons toujours pas la date
de construction du kiosque nous savons
et lequel existait déjà il ya plus de
2000 ans moi je pense que c'est
largement suffisant pour que monsieur
travelling le classe monument historique
au regard des peuples qui ont soit
disparu mais que s'est il passé ça je ne
comprends pas moi je crois que j'ai
compris quand nous sommes partis lumière
ce qui était placée juste comme ça dans
laxe de la machine à remonter dans le
temps donc le kiosque a subi comme nous
les effets de la machine
c'est pour ça que chaque fois que nous
leur étions dans une époque différente
eh bien nous le retrouvions là derrière
nous au même endroit mais oui mais
pourquoi n'est-il pas revenue avec nous
pourquoi c'est certainement cet olibrius
d'autres adeline us qui en touchant ma
machine pas empêché qu'il revienne
ohlala il faut absolument qu'on est fier
du robot monsieur habib bravo bravo je
vois que vous ètes ranger mon été et que
vous nous avez déjà débarrassé de 7 ans
bravo ne me dit rien ne vous dit rien je
cours je cours remettre au travail et je
veux être au travail des petites mains
jeu commencera les travaux
parce que son union au
plus une minute à perdre il faut de
toute urgence retourner chez le kiosque
un point seulement savoir à quel moment
bien disparu
ce devait être
en 48 avant jésus christ non non non moi
je crois que c'est plutôt 23 après
jésus-christ oui mais de quelle qu'elles
s'étaient arrêtées moi je crois
il y avait but de feuilles c'était en
automne mabon mais non c'était au mois
de mai
oui mais de quelle année
voilà qu'elle
attend bien août à août à loder a vu ça
ça repart
[Musique]